faisons ce soir un tour en creuse et
plus particulièrement à guéret où existe
une maison des jeunes
depuis 1946 mais dans l'avenir un autre
centre d'accueil de la jeunesse sera
établie place du champ de foire
d'ailleurs les premiers travaux sont en
cours actuellement 11 200 jeunes qui
viennent en majorité des établissements
scolaires de la ville fréquentent les
locaux mis à leur disposition
ils sont âgés de 14 à 21 ans
ces images vous prouve la variété des
loisirs proposés aux jeunes d'airé toi
qui peuvent en outre sa données dont ils
sont un peu plus âgés au judo
l'haltérophilie et autres sports de
salle
sur le plan culturel à part la
bibliothèque
ils sont six ans à suivre régulièrement
les activités du ciné club
il a même fallu d'ailleurs doubler le
nombre des séances quant aux
photographes ils sont 60 fidèles
chevalier de l'objectif
la radio amateur connaît un succès sans
cesse grandissant
et si vous allez le voir la section des
maquettes forme de futurs aviateurs
c'est un enthousiasme débordant
qu'affichent les philatélistes donc
l'exemple de la maison des jeunes de
guéret est à suivre ici les jeunes
n'osent pas dire nous ne savons que
faire
nous nous ennuyer
il